[Music]
this is us rekt us if you haven't
watched yet look away just drive son
we'll get there Randall and William hit
the road for one last hurrah - Williams
hometown of Memphis
along the way they visit Jack's
unofficial resting place for raising him
to be the man he is I'm sorry I didn't
get a chance to meet your brother I
would have liked to have heard that
laugh I would have liked to admit my
son's father they even stopped by
Williams childhood home and the Memphis
jazz club he used to perform at with his
cousin Ricky things take a turn for the
worse though and William and Randall
shared this gut-wrenching heart-to-heart
you deserved a beautiful life you made
you deserve everything Randall this is
when we say goodbye to William my
beautiful boy
my son now we weren't the only folks
drowning in tears
et caught up with Ron cephus Jones who
plays William he said it was emotional
watching the episode I felt probably
like you felt and anyone else watching
it I'm a big fan of the show too and all
the feelings hit me the same way the
sentiment rang true for Sterling Kay
Brown who shared his thoughts after the
episode on Facebook I'm trying to make
more people cry I've seen the episode
like five or six times way I've seen it
a lot I think it's really how you guys
are experiencing it right now
you